CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell served a CIA
deputy director and acting director he
is the host of the intelligence matters
podcast and joins us from Jackson Hole
Wyoming thank you so much for joining us
on your vacation you tweeted an article
yesterday from a former CIA colleague of
yours who wrote that the US intelligence
community can no longer trust the
president's judgment do you agree and if
that's the case should his intelligence
chiefs resign viana there's been a very
rocky relationship between President
Trump and his intelligence community
you'll remember in the early days the
relationship was bad the morale was bad
the president called his intelligence
community Nazis on people were
considering resigning but over time that
relationship got better in large part
because the intelligence community got
access to the Oval Office on almost a
daily basis but yesterday was a blow to
that morale it was a blow to that
relationship I do think that senior
officials in the intelligence community
need to ask themselves whether they can
continue to serve this president and and
represent the men and women in the
intelligence community in a way that is
positive deeply concerned about that
would you advise them to step down if
they reached out to you for advice I
would advise them to consider stepping
down yes
so Mike imagine this they have
intelligence they would normally share
it with the president what's your view
about whether they should continue to
share intelligence that runs
particularly in along these lines about
relations with Russia
John their job is to inform the
President to keep the president informed
of what they know and what they think
they will not stop doing that
I have high regard very high regard for
the Director of National Intelligence
dan coates he has been very vocal about
the threat that Russia poses to the
United States he's been very vocal about
Russian meddling in the 2016 election
he's been very vocal about what the
Russians are doing in Europe he's been
very vocal about the fact that the
Russians continue to meddle in our
democracy
see to this very day so I would
encourage the intelligence community to
continue to tell the president what they
think and continue to speak publicly
about what they think and what they know
alright Michael Morell thanks so much
again for coming in for us today and
giving us your thoughts